Fabi welcome back to the show the
American Cup did finish but you did win
the American Cup Blitz portion of the
event tell us a bit about this
tournament yeah I think I played three
sections in this tournament first I
played in the Champions bracket then the
elimination bracket and then the
basement bracket and finally we got
relegated
that's amazing and tell us uh what do
you feel was your most difficult
opponent in this one it felt we were
watching the results pile up but it and
it felt quite smooth for you did you
feel the same way overall I think I
played well and it was relatively smooth
um definitely the toughest game was
against left because
I was much worse than I was winning I
think and then I made a very bad
decision and then I had to suffer in a
very unpleasant endgame
uh so that was probably the toughest
game and after that it was it was pretty
smooth I think I played a really good
game against Sam Shanklin that was maybe
my best game I I didn't have a chance to
check with the engine of course what uh
if there were some big mistakes but but
that felt like a good game
and then yeah this game against linear
was the most important one in fact we do
have the end of that game the one
between yourself and Lanier the most
important game for you let's take a look
at that
and that's truly the end of it that
really is the end of the game
let's have a look at that again
it was quick yeah producers are uh yeah
playing mind games
uh guys join the conversation well first
of all uh tell us uh your your
perspective of the match between Wesley
so and Hikaru how do you see this
playing out we've got the playoffs
coming up of game 10 in 5 seconds who do
you like
yeah I actually don't know I mean it
really is very close to 50 50. they
played a bunch of matches in the past
year where they went pretty much down to
the wire I feel like Wesley is probably
playing a bit better at the moment
although he did lose the first match
that they played went to elimination
then one not to get eliminated but I
felt like he was he was out playing him
in all the matches and then Hikaru is uh
super resourceful when it comes down to
the last few seconds
so um
if it gets to Blitz yeah probably Hikaru
should be a favorite
but
um yeah it's going to be so close and
also these games these matches of two
games you know they're always a tussle
hmm
Jody
no I was I was going to ask Fabiano um
so do you think it would make an impact
that Hikaru lost his much against Wesley
tomorrow
yeah for sure that that put some
momentum in Wesley's favor uh that's a
big blow because I'm sure Hikaru wanted
to end it yesterday and also to play The
Blitz today
so I mean of course he's he's going to
to fight very hard anyway it's not like
he's going to collapse psychologically
but the momentum definitely shifted
Wesley's favor after that
one of the things that was striking to
my eyes was when we compared their live
ratings and in Blitz it was actually
Hikaru number two Wesley all the way to
number 19. do you feel that that is the
big discrepancy that might decide this
match well I think Blitz ratings are
also very volatile you have one bad
event and any rating tanks um like
Hikaru I think gained this 2900 rating
because in the last year in the St Louis
um
wrapped in Blitz he he basically
it was he and Ali Reza they both kind of
ran away with it but alireza had the
better Rapids so so he won the
tournament but Hikaru was like basically
winning all his Blitz Games then hikar
also did well in the world championship
I think he got silver
but uh but his 2900 was gained in that
rapid Woods last year and I don't know
where Wesley lost his rating but you
know these with blitz sometimes you you
lose a lot in one tournament because
it's like if you're in bad form you can
lose you know 50 100 points in a day it
doesn't really happen in classical and
and likewise you could also win a ton of
raiding so
um I wouldn't say that there's like a
huge qualitative difference between car
and Wesley of course Hikaru should be by
results the better Blitz player but it's
going to be a very slight difference and
it could depend a lot on you know the
Forum on that particular day how they're
feeling mentally if they slept enough
things like that you know these players
so well and one thing that we've seen
with Wesley whenever he plays this ten
plus five
he usually goes down to his last three
four minutes very often he car was on
eight nine minutes and then he starts
speeding up in the middle game and he
really puts a lot of pressure with
precise moves in the middle game tell us
a bit about that how do you see it yeah
I've noticed that Wesley really really
tries to avoid severe time travel like
very uh consistently as opposed to other
players like let's say Levon or linear
especially they don't they don't shy
away from time pressure as much Wesley I
think realizes that he he loses control
even if you're even if you're super
strong you're going to lose control and
time pressure and he tries to avoid that
scenario and we saw that when he was
beating Nakamura objectively winning and
that that absolutely crazy game that he
lost
um when I sacrifice The Rook at the end
yeah yeah I mean the game was crazy and
actually very impressive up to that
point and then it was like a kind of
inexplicable decision to take on E6 yeah
but uh he was winning and he was out
playing Hikaru and then once he got down
to seconds and Hikaru of course is is
probably the best in the world at these
sort of things like setting up chances
and tricks I think he and he and Magnus
like the this B3 and uh trying to set up
some sort of uh even if it's not
objectively the the best setting up some
sort of potential shots potential that
if things go wrong for white then they
really go wrong and that's what happened
um and Wesley once he got down to
seconds he couldn't keep control of the
situation which I mean I can also relate
to uh very often also lose control when
I'm down to my last two seconds of last
few seconds
so so he's trying to avoid that for sure
while Hikaru I think he he is incredibly
strong like if it's just time scramble
he's he's definitely better than Wesley
Fabi we're not going to see you here in
St Louis for a while what's next for you
in the next couple of months well I'll
be in St Louis you just won't see me I'm
always sticking around for a bit and
then I have like the grand house tour
starts
um also we'll probably be doing
something for the world championship
uh not not playing of course
unfortunately but talking about it uh
discussing the match
uh so that'll be fun and then the the
grand chess tour starts first uh
Bucharest and then like all the
tournaments start again it's going to be
kind of hectic hectic schedule awesome
congratulations for the victory in the
blitz event we'll see you soon thanks